how long should it take for you to write
the first draft of a screenplay
like what's your typical turnaround time
for the first draft
oh it's interesting because usually the
way i
write a script is i'm usually working on
another
finishing the previous movie so
what i tend to do is i tend to use a
certain amount of my free time
on developing the story and jotting down
ideas
and i can spend a long time jotting down
ideas while i'm working on something
else
and then once you reach the critical
mass and there's enough ideas jotted
down
then it's just a matter of me going yes
i'm going to write that into a script
and finding the time to do it
and i can usually buckle down at that
point after having spent all that time
with the ideas and developing the
characters are there and i know the
basic plot
i know the basic set pieces all that's
been you know
slowly accumulated over months and
months by doing something else the first
draft can happen really fast
first draft can be done in in a couple
of weeks if that's all i'm doing
if i'm able to have a couple weeks
straight well all i can do is to sit
down and write you know 10 or 12 hours a
day
boom you can do the first draft but the
first draft is the start
of the process the first draft is kind
of like just you taking all those notes
and putting it
into a form where you go ah it's a
script and then at that point
then you can really start i i show it to
lo laurence and and and she looks at it
and we can start the process of like
figuring out what what seems to be
working what what scenes are great
well there should be more scenes like
that this this scene it's like
obviously she won't be mad if i say it
but sometimes she'll so like early on i
would write a script and she would like
i i love the first the first initial
notes on the first draft are fantastic
and sometimes they'll be like
giant x's on a page like boring
you know but it's great because it
basically you're getting those outside
eyes
to know like what's engaging what's
capturing you
and then the other part of it is of
course on the drafts it's like shrinking
everything down
everything to its core essence uh so you
don't have any repetition
in terms of scenes repetition in terms
of locations or
characters doing the same thing it kind
of like for me what i've learned over
the years
is you basically like what's the latest
you can get into a scene and the
earliest you can get out
you know it's like how and how can you
make that work and flow
uh and from an editing standpoint and
also low as
a shooter and cinematographer like we
spent a lot of time
um a lot of time with echoes of fear our
last one when we were
doing the different scripts was figuring
out like um
you know how we can make that flow
really nicely whereas the beginning of
the movie we passed through about two
and a half weeks of time
in the first 20 minutes of the movie we
go through about two and a half weeks
and we have a lot of like short scenes
like actually if you clock them there
are like scenes they're 25 seconds
so a lot of it was like figuring out in
the script stage like how to dovetail
the audio
hit the scene have everything still flow
so even though you have all these like
really really short scenes and you're
passing time and you're going
you know in as late as you can and out
as early as you can
but you can't be like disjointed
everything has to flow in terms of the
visual and the edit
and that that first starts with working
that out in the script
and then of course when you get into
post you some you know you push that
even further
but he has to start in the script stage
you know it has to be
thought out that way in the beginning so
you know like these are the moments
in the scene which will bridge us and
visually into the next scene and stuff
so it's exciting to me it's like
that's i mean i love the process of
doing the multiple drafts
on the script and and honing it to me
like honing the story is is the most fun
the most daunting is probably like
getting all those initial ideas together
and getting through that first draft
because once you have that then you you
can just play
on all the different versions and just
keep making it better
the same way like when you finish the
movie you keep editing it to make it
better you keep
you know you finish your first version
which is your script
and then like forget the script now we
got this and then you start
letting the movie tell you what it wants
to be and start playing and edit
to like figure out how to even make it
tighter and better
and take it to the next step in the
editing room so then of course music and
sound design
that's really the icing on the kick when
you get to get to that level
you think your experience as an editor
has really helped with the storytelling
i think so because even when i started
um like by the time i was doing
my second or third shorts i guess by the
time i was like 12 years old
i was editing at that point i was
shooting super eight and believe me when
you shoot
an edit super 8 and you are physically
cutting the film and then having to tape
it back together
you think about why you're editing
because because it's like that is a
process
so you really are editing in your head
because it was difficult you edit in
your head so
as a kid i was like you already started
editing in your head because of the
difficulty of
splicing that super 8 film and putting
it together so i kind of like
learn that and internalize that and then
what you learn is what you start doing
is you start editing in your head before
you even shoot
so before you even shoot anything you're
storyboarding
and you're storyboarding and out from
the edit in your head
and in that in that so it's like you're
editing even from the very beginning of
course that changes
because things on the set and it's very
organic and things may change from your
storyboards and they may change from the
edit in your head when you actually get
into physically
truly editing what you shot but i think
you're just always editing
i think and same with writing and the
same way when you're writing your
editing you're editing the scene
to figure out to make it shorter or
tighter in the words and
do they need to say all those words do
they need to say any words
you know is is it can this just be
expressed by an expression
so it may start out in your first draft
it's a paragraph speech from someone
which turns into maybe three words
so in a way it's like i think editing is
the essence of
telling a story is is editing whether it
be
like editing in your writing or editing
in your head when you're storyboarding
before you shoot or
truly the editing what's called editing
when you're editing your
your finished product so even if i
reached a point where i would be using
another editor which i would not be
against at all
in terms of the physical editing i still
think the process
would be a lot of editing would be going
on in my head
uh you know so yeah i think it's just
like a key
element for me is seeing i see it
visually
and that's how i got into making uh
movies to begin with
as opposed to like doing short story
writing or writing novels
as much is that i i i see it in my head
this is how the story comes to me so
in a way even when i'm writing the
script
i'm watching it in my head
sometimes i wish you could just jack a
little cable into your brain you know
it would be pretty awesome maybe one day
that's going to happen everyone's going
to be able to do their own movies
because they're going to be able to do
it
but then you have to really think about
it i guess or your your movie will be
pretty jumbled but
yeah like charging an electric car yeah
yeah
but then sometimes that's the challenge
is you see it in your head in
in on an independent level when you're
fighting with your budget
and it can be very challenging and
frustrating because you have this movie
in your head
and you're trying to get to that it
wasn't until we did echoes of fear
for the first time i felt like i got
something better than what was in my
head
and to me i definitely think it's the
best film we've done lo and i have done
together
and uh and it was such an amazing
feeling to watch the finished movie and
go
that's better than what i edited in my
head
before i did it and made me so happy
because usually the other movies i would
watch
and i was like happy with dark remains
or a third movie because i felt like i
got 80
of what was in my head and i was like oh
wow this is an amazing accomplishment i
got 80
what i saw in my head so to actually get
something better than i saw in my head
really made me feel like okay we finally
we finally got
it we probably figured it out so it's
pretty nice well plus you hear so many
filmmakers say it wasn't the movie i
thought i was gonna make
like it it got away from me once we got
in the edit room
it wasn't it was still i'm still happy
with it or whatever
but it wasn't the movie i want you know
because because i you have this fantasy
of how we want something to turn out
right and then you're dealing with so
many elements on set
right and things just get away and so
that's well the real magic is when you
can like what happened with us with
echoes of fear their own magic
is when the movie takes on a life of its
own and becomes something
better than what was in your head and
that i feel like is when you finally
break through the wall
is when that happens and i think the
really great movies
that's when the magic happens is when it
actually becomes something
beyond it's like you just reach a point
where all the elements come together
and it goes a step beyond what you even
had imagined
and then i i feel like then to me that's
like to me it's like the really
rewarding experience
because otherwise you're just chasing
what's in your head and it can become
very frustrating
i mean i guess unless you're david lynch
have 100 million dollars and
then by golly you'll get what's in your
head you know
because you've got the resources and
money to do it but you know there's
probably 10 directors in the world who
can actually call you know have the
resources to be able to truly
do no matter what to accomplish their
vision it's very difficult
i'm sure even if you ask some of those
those directors they would probably
maybe who knows say well it sort of is
but you know how everyone's critical of
their own work right right
yeah they hear us something that we
would never even notice
you're right you know sound of a
footstep that they thought
wasn't you know but a lot of people like
i bet you like martin scorsese
doesn't stop editing a movie until
martin scorsese decides
it's he's ready to stop editing oh sure
sure yeah but
this is great about it yeah it's like
when you can reach a level to have that
level of talent
and be able to be recognized so you get
the resources
because people respect your talent and
your vision that's a truly amazing thing
that's true but then there's new
pressure yes of course because then
now if for whatever reason some critic
who's never made a film before
right decides to trash it right and and
tell you how it's all wrong right right
so
yeah true but that's another video
you